So you tell me Matt did a review of the
Little Professor? Was he all ironic
about it?
[Matt] It's if he's staring at
you through a frosted bathroom window...
(Brady: I think that it would
be fair to say there)
(was sarcasm.)
- [Matt] Controversially, as opposed
to me asking the calculator a question
and it giving me the answer, we're doing
this the other way around.
- How dare he!
How dare he? Because the Little Professor
was a major influence on my young
mathematical career. Because I had a
Little Professor when I was a kid and
this is it.
- (Brady: That's the same one?)
The is the one I had yep.
This is my Little
Professor. So did the one that Matt
showed you, was it different?
(Very, it had like an LCD screen.)
- That is a
pretender. Whatever Matt showed you, that
is not the Little Professor; this is the
Little Professor. So this is the real
thing, this is mine. It has seen life I've
lost the back of it through childhood
rubbishness. So I had this- mad I know, it
was a birthday or Christmas or something
when I was eight, something like that?
This gives me warm nostalgic feelings
this- I my love my, this Little Professor
guy. There he is, look at him with his
glasses and his mustache and his
mortarboard. I've looked up what the
history of the Little Professor was, and
it was- they were first devised in 1976,
it was the world's first electronic
educational toy. So that's a claim to
fame. This is the second generation, this
comes from the 1980s. But not an LCD
screen, an LED screen - yeah this
is how we
did things in the early 1980s. So we're on
level one, and we're going to do plus
problems. So the Little Professor would
set you arithmetic problems. You get ten
arithmetic problems, they'd be either
plus problems, subtraction problems,
division, multiplication problems. There's
four levels: level one,
two, three, and four
going from easy to hard.
And I think when I was eight I could do
the hard multiplication problems? Shall
we see if I can still do the
hard multiplication-?
(If you want to put your
reputation on the line.)
I am putting my reputation on
the line. So we're going to do
multiplication problems; I'm going to
level four. I'll put some warnings in
advance, sometimes the buttons are
sticky, sometimes they're all- they're a
bit- sometimes they don't accept what I
press and that-
- (Yeah, whatever.)
It- this happens!
- (All right...)
Go! Alright I've got 24- man
that's hard! 24 by
26. So what is 24 by 26? Let's see, so
52...520...
520 plus four lots of 26... so
we're up to 600-
624.
Yes! That was a tough one!
(That was a hard-)
- That was tough for a
first one, yeah! This is- there you go 24
by 6.
24 by 6; let's do 5 times. So-
(I can do that)
- Go on then.
(That's 144?)
Let's see, I reckon it is. 144?
1 - 4 - 4, alright.
This meant something to me, this is
important! It means something to me now.
So this encouraged my mathematical
interests perhaps; well what it does is-
if you're a kid who gets arithmetic
early on then it's very easy to be
validated, to be encouraged because when
you're given lists of arithmetic
problems it's very easy to get ticks.
Which makes you feel good and it
encourages you and you get ooh, I'm good
at maths! People say, well done you're
very good at maths. You think, oh I
must be good at
maths. And you do feel encouraged and you
do take it on further. Now
I would argue that arithmetic is not
maths; now that I'm an older
mathematician. Arithmetic is part of
maths, it's a small part of maths but it's
not maths - it's not what I do. It's not
what I do for a living, I don't do
arithmetic for a living. But you can- yeh,
definitely things like this would
encourage a young mathematician, someone
who's got some ability that way - this is
encouraging to take it further. I've kept
this, as you can tell. It survived other
toys being thrown out when I was a
teenager. At university I did maths so I
thought, oh well that's
act- that's actually
quite fun to keep around now cos-
(You didn't take that to
university?)
No I didn't take it to
university. When- but I
thought, if I become like a doctor of
maths;
now I did not say to anyone that I had
any ambition to be a doctor of maths, that
was a thought in the back of my head. I
thought maybe, if I do well at university,
maybe I could be like a doctor of maths
that'd be cool. I didn't- I didn't know
I was going to pass my exams
but I thought
maybe. Wouldn't it be nice if it when I'm
a super important Professor to still
have this? And I can keep this in a glass
case in my office - because we look alike
so it would be nice to keep around. And
that's what I did. So I went to my
parents' house I grabbed it there,
it's now living in my house and one day
it's going to take pride of place.
(Numberphile Museum!)
- Numberphile Mus- do you know
oh don't- do you know you can see-
they have these in museums now. If you go
to the Science Museum in London they
have one of these in a glass
case. How old do I feel?
(Brady: Lastly, in our videos)
(about calculators we traditionally like)
(do a test, like a durability test, like)
(destroy them or set fire to them and I'm)
(guessing we're not doing that?)
- Get out.
Get- don't even think abou- out.